This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. And then see if you can begin to deepen your breath here, nice long inhale in, and a nice long juicy exhale out. There are some commonly accepted ideas about what it means to be healthy. Healthy people eat lots of fruits and vegetables. They don't do drugs, and of course they exercise. Draw your palms together at the heart, take a deep breath in each time we get here. While physical activity and food dominate our discussions about well-being,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。接下来看看你是否能在这里开始加深呼吸，深深地吸气，再痛快地长长呼气。关于健康的含义，有一些普遍共识。健康的人吃大量的水果和蔬菜，不吸毒，当然还要锻炼身体。把双手合十放在胸前，每次来到这里时都要深吸一口气。虽然身体活动和饮食主导了我们关于幸福感的讨论，
the importance of social interaction is often overlooked. I think the movie was better than the book. I'm alright. What's your horse go? I like a large-scale- Long time no see! There's a large, ongoing body of research about how critical social contact is to human survival. That awful looks so good on you, where do you go to choose?
社交互动的价值却经常被忽视。我觉得这部电影比书好看。我挺好的。你压的是哪匹马？我喜欢大规模的——好久不见！关于社会接触对人类生存有多么重要，目前有大量持续进行的研究。这件衣服穿在你身上太好看了，你要去选哪一件？
A University of Utah's studies showed that people with strong relationships have lower blood pressure than lonely counterparts. I've got two redepth books, though. It's time for you to get a watch. I'm a huge character. Researchers at the University of Chicago found that people who report strong feelings of loneliness
犹他大学的一项研究表明，人际关系紧密的人比孤独的人血压更低。不过我有两本深度阅读的书。你该去买块手表了。我是一个性格很强的人。芝加哥大学的研究人员发现，那些报告有强烈孤独感的人
are more likely to binge eat. That plays as the best of it. That plays have the worst. I'll take two spoons of mint chocolate chips. And at Harvard, one study found that people with good relationships actually live longer and live happier. Happy birthday, baby. Our social ties are unquestionably at the core
更容易暴饮暴食。那是其中最好的一段。那是其中最糟的一段。我要两勺薄荷巧克力芯片冰淇淋。而在哈佛大学，一项研究发现，人际关系良好的人实际上寿命更长，生活也更快乐。生日快乐，宝贝。我们的社会纽带毫无疑问是
of what it means to be human. Anything good on that? I just got back from Vogue or something. Are you going to have your answer tonight? I'm trying to have a dinner. Have you worked? All right, so let's go. Let's go. So what happens if you're cut off from human contact? We want to have you out tonight. Dinner? After work? That's a pleasure.
人性的核心。那个有什么好看的吗？我刚从Vogue还是什么地方回来。你今晚能给出答复吗？我在努力安排吃晚饭。你工作了吗？好吧，那我们走吧。我们走吧。那么，如果你与人类社会隔绝，会发生什么？我们今晚想约你出去。晚饭？下班后？那太荣幸了。
So what happens if you're cut off from human contact? LITER IN THE SHOW We talk about the effects of long-term solitary confinement. People talk about not having seen the moon in years or decades and how much they miss that. And then people talk about missing just pure human touch. First though, we start by exploring the other end of the spectrum, interaction overload.
那么，如果你与人类社会隔绝，会发生什么？节目预告 我们将讨论长期单独禁闭的影响。人们谈到已经好几年甚至几十年没见过月亮了，以及他们多么怀念月亮。接着，人们谈到怀念纯粹的人类触碰。不过首先，我们要探讨光谱的另一端：互动过载。
In her 20s and 30s, Rachel Leonard lived all over the United States. El Encalorado and upstate New York and I lived in Vermont for a long time and then I was living in Asheville, North Carolina. And she traveled all over the world. She met lots of different people in all these places. To keep in touch with them, she signed up for Facebook.
在20多和30多岁时，蕾切尔·伦纳德在美国各地生活过。埃尔恩卡拉多和纽约州北部，我在佛蒙特州住了很长时间，然后住在北卡罗来纳州的阿什维尔。她还去了世界各地旅行。她在所有这些地方遇到了形形色色的人。为了与他们保持联系，她注册了Facebook。
I was traveling in Central America, 2006 and 2007, and I did not have a phone, and I was in pretty remote areas. I signed up then because I kept meeting all these wonderful people, and one of the ways to immediately connect with them was to friend them on Facebook. The site became an important tool for Rachel, to keep in touch with people she'd met on her travels to share her adventures with friends and family back home.
2006年和2007年我在中美洲旅行，当时没有手机，而且身处相当偏远的地区。我就是在那时注册的，因为我不断遇到所有这些美好的人，而与他们立即建立联系的方法之一就是在Facebook上加他们为好友。这个网站成了蕾切尔的重要工具，用来与她在旅行中遇到的人保持联系，并与家乡的朋友和家人分享她的冒险经历。
That's actually when I started sharing like my travels with other friends, my pictures of my trip. But as much as Rachel loved traveling and felt good about the choices she'd made in her life, other feelings started to sneak up on her. Having Facebook also allowed her to see what everyone else was up to, while she was back packing in Central America, or moving from one city to another. You know, everybody's getting married. Some people have one child, some people have two children.
其实也就是从那时起，我开始和其他朋友分享我的旅行，分享我的旅行照片。但尽管蕾切尔热爱旅行，并为自己生活中做出的选择感到高兴，其他一些情绪还是开始悄悄涌上心头。拥有Facebook也让她得以看到其他人在忙些什么，而当时她正在中美洲背包旅行，或是从一个城市搬到另一个城市。你知道的，每个人都在结婚。有些人有一个孩子，有些人有两个孩子。
All my friends have these high-powered jobs, and they own own houses and all of these things. These feelings were at the back of her mind a few years later when she met a guy and decided to start a relationship. I met him and I had been planning to leave the country and go to Southeast Asia to teach and I met him in December and I was supposed to leave in June and I didn't go. A new boyfriend asked her to stay with him in Asheville, North Carolina. She wasn't sure it was the right thing to do, but she agreed. It was a turning point in my life in lots of ways because up until then I'd kind of been this free spirit
我的所有朋友都有光鲜体面的工作，他们拥有自己的房子以及所有这些东西。几年后，当她遇到一个男孩并决定开始一段恋爱关系时，这些感受仍然留存在她脑海深处。我遇到了他，当时我本来计划离开这个国家去东南亚教书，我是在12月遇到他的，我本该在6月离开，但最终我没有去。新男友让她留在北卡罗来纳州的阿什维尔。她不确定这样做是否正确，但她还是答应了。这在很多方面都是我人生的转折点，因为在此之前我一直是个自由不羁的人，
and did what I wanted and traveled a lot and still had that wanderlust. But I was also 33 and kind of looking around and realizing that other people were getting married and having kids and I decided maybe I should try this out. Soon, like so many of her friends, she was posting pictures and details about her happy relationship. We got engaged pretty quickly. And, you quickly and at this time I'm posting my pictures and posting our hikes.
想做什么就做什么，经常旅行，而且依然有着那种对远方的渴望。但我也33岁了，环顾四周，意识到其他人都在结婚生子，我决定或许我也该尝试一下。很快，就像她的许多朋友一样，她开始发布关于她幸福恋情的照片和细节。我们很快就订婚了。而且，在这个时候，我发着自己的照片，发着我们的远足照片。
We lived in the Blue Ridge Mountain, so we'd have these beautiful hikes in this lovely little town, and of course I'm posting all of this. Her engagement was chronicled, the new house they moved into, the view from the porch. All of it looked beautiful on Facebook. If you looked only from the porch, you could see mountains straight, but if you looked to the left, you could see this huge factory. But of course, I didn't take pictures of the factory because why would you do that? Because Facebook is not a place for pictures of ugly factories.
我们住在蓝岭山脉，所以我们会在这座可爱的小镇进行美丽的远足，当然我把这一切都发到了网上。她的订婚过程被记录了下来，他们搬进去的新房子，门廊上的风景。这一切在Facebook上看起来都很完美。如果你只从门廊看出去，你可以直接看到群山，但如果你往左看，你能看到这座巨大的工厂。但当然，我没有拍工厂的照片，因为你为什么要那样做呢？因为Facebook不是放丑陋工厂照片的地方。
It was very taboo not to share positivity. You know, one ever put negative stuff on there. And if they did, people were like, hmm, what's going on with blah, blah, blah. So it was always about being positive and showing your best side and your best moments. Facebook is also not a place for ambivalence. Celebrating triumph, that's welcome. Morning of tragedy, that's okay too. Expressing uncertainty and doubt?
不分享积极向上的内容是非常禁忌的。你知道的，从来没有人会在上面发布负面内容。如果他们真的发了，人们就会想，嗯，某某某怎么了？所以重点永远是保持积极，展现你最好的一面和最美好的时刻。Facebook同样也不是一个容纳矛盾心理的地方。庆祝胜利，那是受欢迎的。哀悼悲剧，那也没问题。表达不确定和怀疑？
Not so much. We all intuitively understand the rules. Posts about engagements and babies will receive ravenous applause. News about a grandparent passing away will elicit virtual hugs, but fears about not making rent, marital tensions, hesitations about becoming apparent, those are verboten.
那就没那么受欢迎了。我们都凭直觉理解这些规则。关于订婚和婴儿的帖子会收获狂热的喝彩。关于祖父母去世的消息会引发虚拟的拥抱，但对交不起房租的恐惧、婚姻的紧张、对成为父母的犹豫，这些都是禁忌。
Rachel started to feel constricted. The more she posted about her happy life on social media, the greater the disconnect she felt with her real life. I know now that at the time, while it looked great and it looked right, it didn't really feel right for me, but I think that putting it out there and having my friends say, oh, this looks so wonderful, you look so happy, this is great, it was kind of my way of convincing myself it was. And I'd say that the more things didn't feel great, the more I posted.
蕾切尔开始感到受到束缚。她在社交媒体上发布的幸福生活越多，她就越觉得与真实生活脱节。我现在知道，当时虽然看起来很棒也很正确，但对我来说其实并没有那种感觉，但我认为，把它发出去，让我的朋友们说，哦，这看起来太棒了，你看起来好幸福，这太棒了，这在某种程度上成了我用来连自己也一起说服的方式。而且我想说，事情越是没有那种美好的感觉，我发得就越多。
The golf widened between her real relationship and the Facebook version. What I'm not posting is that we fought a lot and what seemed to be kind of perfect to other people was not. When the new couple took a trip to Charleston, Rachel says her friends on Facebook only saw the beautiful pictures. She boasted photos of the two of them sitting on the beach, drinking memoses, eating good food. And really we were fighting the entire time. I had actually tried to break up with him. And it was a miserable trip.
她的真实恋情与Facebook版本之间的鸿沟越来越大。我没有发的是我们经常吵架，在其他人看来似乎很完美的事情其实并不完美。当这对新情侣去查尔斯顿旅行时，蕾切尔说她在Facebook上的朋友们只看到了那些美丽的图片。她炫耀了两人坐在海滩上、喝着含羞草鸡尾酒、吃着美食的照片。而实际上我们整个过程都在吵架。我其实曾试图和他分手。那是一次痛苦的旅行。
But I didn't tell anybody that. And I, you know, what I shared was the pictures of us in front of the fountain or at the aquarium or eating something delicious, and not that we fought 90% of the time. You're kind of curating your life. Just these very specific moments, the best of the best that you're putting up there with no context.
但我没有告诉任何人，而且，你知道的，我分享的是我们站在喷泉前、在水族馆里或吃着美味食物的照片，而不是我们90%的时间都在吵架。你其实是在精心策展你的人生。把这些非常特定的时刻，也就是最好中的最好，在没有任何背景的情况下放到网上去。
More and more, Rachel found that she was turning to social media for validation. She wanted confirmation from her social media for validation. She wanted confirmation from her social media feed that her life was on track. The more she posted photos of her relationship, the more positive feedback she got. Like, I'm so happy for you. You're finally settling down because I'd been traveling forever and you know you look great, you two look beautiful together. So Rachel convinced herself that this was what she wanted. She had constructed a beautiful version of the truth
蕾切尔越来越发现，她正转向社交媒体来寻求认可。她希望从社交媒体上获得确认，以证明自己的人生正走在正轨上。她发布的恋爱照片越多，得到的积极反馈也就越多。比如，我为你感到高兴。你终于安定下来了，因为我一直在旅行，你知道你看上去真棒，你们两个站在一起真般配。于是蕾切尔说服自己，这就是她想要的生活。她构建了一个美丽的真相版本，
and now she felt she had to live it. She got married, posted photos of the wedding. She says that she and her husband moved to a new city. They both got jobs, they bought a house, put down roots. You know, on the outside it looked like we had this beautiful new house and he had this great new job and I had this great new job
而现在她觉得自己必须按照这个版本去生活。她结婚了，发布了婚礼的照片。她说她和丈夫搬到了一个新城市。他们俩都找到了工作，买了一座房子，扎下了根。你知道的，从表面上看，我们好像拥有了一栋美丽的新房子，他有了一份很棒的新工作，我也有了一份很棒的新工作，
and still things were not good. The house looked beautiful from the outside but ended up being costly and difficult to fix. Worse than that, Rachel increasingly felt she was with the wrong person. The best way that I can put it is that we were just not suited for each other. And I knew it.
然而事情依然很不妙。房子从外面看起来很漂亮，结果却花费高昂且很难修缮。更糟糕的是，蕾切尔越来越觉得她选错了人。我能想到的最好表达方式就是，我们根本不适合彼此。而且我心知肚明。
You think that part of my psyche was just trying to ignore all of these signs that were just this person and I were not, we were not matched well. Rachel quickly got pregnant. She had a difficult pregnancy, but again, that wasn't something she shared on social media. It was taboo to say that this doesn't feel good. This is really hard, as if you're not grateful that you were pregnant.
你觉得我心理的一部分只是在试图忽视所有这些迹象，我和这个人根本就不合拍，我们并不般配。蕾切尔很快就怀孕了。她的孕期很艰难，但同样地，这不是她在社交媒体上分享的内容。说出“这感觉一点也不好，这真的很难”是禁忌，这就好像你对怀孕不够感恩一样。
And instead of being able to say those things out loud, I just posted pictures of my growing belly and, you know, cute things and working on the nursery and, you know, things like that, instead of really focusing or sharing what was going on for me internally. The unhappy original felt, the more she posted. And she spent a lot of time looking at other people's posts too. I would just scour other people's lives. I would just, to compare, you know, their happiness against my happiness, you know.
与其大声说出这些感受，我只是发布我日益隆起的肚子的照片，还有，你知道的，一些可爱的事情，以及布置婴儿房的照片，你知道的，诸如此类的事情，而不是真正去关注或分享我内心深处的真实感受。现实中的不快乐感越深，她发帖就越多。而且她也花了很多时间看别人的帖子。我会去搜寻别人的生活。我只会去比较，你知道的，他们的幸福和我的幸福，你知道的。
And I felt like I shouldn't be feeling the way I was feeling. It seemed like the grass was always greener for everyone else. Everyone else seemed more successful, happier in their marriages, having more fun with their pregnancies and the early days of motherhood. Eventually, Rachel's marriage fell apart. She said she decided to move back to Cleveland where her family is from, along with her son. And in that moment, something happened. You know, what was really interesting was when I knew I was moving back to Cleveland, I was trying to kind of put feelers out there because I knew I needed to find a job. And I didn't know how to say it without really saying what was going on.
我觉得自己不应该有那样的感受。在其他人看来，草似乎总是更绿。每个人看起来都更成功，婚姻更美满，在孕期和初为人母的日子里也过得更有趣。最终，蕾切尔的婚姻破裂了。她说她决定带着儿子搬回老家克利夫兰。就在那一刻，发生了一件事。你知道的，真正有趣的是，当我得知自己要搬回克利夫兰时，我试图试探一下风向，因为我知道我需要找一份工作。而我不知道该怎么说，才能既不说出真实情况又能表达诉求。
And so I, you know, posted that my son and I were coming back to Cleveland and we'd be there in June and I was looking for some, you know, a new adventure or something like that, put some spin on it. And I got so many private messages from friends of mine who were like, are you guys getting divorced? Blah blah blah. And I have been separated for six months or we're getting divorced or I've been divorced for two years. I had no idea. These are people who I looked at their lives and
所以，你知道的，我发了一条动态，说我和儿子要回克利夫兰了，我们会在6月到达那里，我在寻找一些，你知道的，新的冒险之类的东西，稍微粉饰了一下。我收到了很多朋友的私信，他们问：你们是要离婚吗？巴拉巴拉。而我其实已经分居六个月了，或者说我们正在离婚，或者我已经离婚两年了。我完全不知道。这些人都是我曾审视过他们生活的人，
Maybe if I hadn't been so hyper focused on my life, I would have maybe noticed that their husbands were not in all the pictures anymore. It was eye-opening. Once the spell was broken Rachel realized something. I look at social media differently now. In fact, when people are posting a ton of stuff, I'm always kind of like, hmm, I wonder what other story is happening, not that there has to be doom and gloom and negativity, but there's always another story.
也许如果我不是那么高度关注我自己的生活，我可能就会注意到他们的照片里再也没有出现他们的丈夫了。这真是大开眼界。一旦魔咒解除，蕾切尔意识到了一件事。我现在对社交媒体的看法不同了。事实上，当人们发布大量内容时，我总是会想：嗯，我想知道背后还有什么别的故事，倒不是说一定要有什么厄运、阴霾和负能量，但总归还有另一个故事。
There's always something else going on. There's context you could never pick up if you didn't know. There's always another story. We might know this intellectually, but we still often feel a sense of social comparison when we look at our social media feeds. So, it's not that you think that others are happier than you are, but you need to prove yourself to yourself over and over again, and this social comparison engagement makes you less happy. When we come back, we'll explore how the amount of time you spend on social media can determine how happy you are.
总是有其他的事情在发生。如果你不知情，永远也无法捕捉到其中的背景。总是有另一个故事。我们理智上可能明白这一点，但当浏览社交媒体动态时，我们仍然经常感到一种社会比较的心理。所以，倒不是说你认为别人比你更幸福，而是你需要一次又一次地向自己证明你自己，而这种参与社会比较的行为会让你变得不那么快乐。等我们回来，我们将探讨你在社交媒体上花费的时间如何决定你的幸福感。
Stay with us. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. All over the world, in every language and culture, Truman is the ultimate media star. Uniting is all, history's greatest entertainment endeavor. The Truman Show. In the 1998 movie The Truman Show, Jim Carrey is the star of his own reality TV show, but he doesn't know it. His entire world is constructed by producers, his wife, his kids,
请继续收听。这里是美国国家公共电台。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在世界各地，在每一种语言和文化中，杜鲁门都是终极的传媒明星。将我们所有人凝聚在一起，这是历史上最伟大的娱乐盛举。《楚门的世界》。在1998年的电影《楚门的世界》中，金·凯瑞是一档真人秀节目的明星，但他自己并不知道。他的整个世界都是由制片人构建的，他的妻子、他的孩子、
his colleagues, they're all actors. His life is a series of scenes shot to appeal to an audience. Truman's life is as real as anyone else's life. It's merely, slightly planned. Truman eventually found that living inside a television set kept him from discovering his real life. Like Truman, many of us today find ourselves living inside a carefully curated world. The difference? These worlds are of our own making, On Facebook, Instagram, and Twitter. When I first heard Rachel Leonard's story, I kept thinking about a tragic irony. She constructed
他的同事，全都是演员。他的人生是一系列为了迎合观众而拍摄的场景。楚门的人生和其他任何人的人生一样真实。它仅仅是，被稍微规划了一下。楚门最终发现，生活在电视机里面阻碍了他去发现真实的人生。就像楚门一样，我们当中的许多人如今也发现自己生活在一个精心策展的世界里。不同之处在于？这些世界是我们自己创造的，在Facebook、Instagram和Twitter上。当我第一次听到蕾切尔·伦纳德的故事时，我一直想到一个悲剧性的讽刺。她构建了
a fake world to keep up with the happy lives of all her friends on Facebook. But many of her friends were doing exactly the same thing. They were trying to keep up with her. Everyone was posting pictures of their beautiful vacation, no one was saying anything about the fight that had during the cartridge. What I'm not posting is that we fought a lot. You don't need me to tell you that there are many wonderful things about social media.
一个虚假的世界，来跟上Facebook上所有朋友的幸福生活。但她的许多朋友也在做着完全相同的事情。他们试图跟上她的步伐。每个人都在发布自己美好假期的照片，却没有一个人提及他们在卡车旅行中发生的争吵。我没有发的是我们经常吵架。你不需要我来告诉你，社交媒体有很多美好的地方。
It gives us an easy way to stay in touch with people we care about. But many studies have shown that people who use social media frequently appear to be unhappier than those who don't. Until recently, it was impossible to say whether this was correlation or causation. Do lonely people spend more time on social media in an effort to escape their loneliness or is social media itself causing people to feel isolated. A recent study at Tel Aviv University has provided what may be the first experiment to sort out correlation from causation. Yes, so my name is Ohad Barzilei,
它为我们提供了一种便捷的方式，与我们关心的人保持联系。但许多研究表明，频繁使用社交媒体的人似乎比不用的人更不快乐。直到最近，我们还无法确定这究竟是相关性还是因果关系。是孤独的人为了逃避孤独而在社交媒体上花更多时间，还是社交媒体本身导致人们感到孤立。特拉维夫大学最近的一项研究提供了可能是第一项厘清相关性与因果关系的实验。是的，我叫奥哈德·巴尔齐莱，
and I am a faculty member at the Colors School of Management in Tel Aviv University. Ohad and his colleagues wanted a test where the spending time on Facebook actually made people feel worse. They happened on what psychologists call a natural experiment. A security firm in Israel decided to restrict the Facebook use of its employees. No one was allowed to use Facebook at all for security reasons.
我是特拉维夫大学科勒管理学院的教职员工。奥哈德和他的同事们想要测试在Facebook上花时间是否真的会让人们感觉更糟。他们偶然发现了心理学家所说的自然实验。以色列的一家安全公司决定限制员工使用Facebook。出于安全原因，任何人都不准使用Facebook。
The employees had to delete their accounts if they wanted to continue working for the company. But then, after some time, the firm decided to allow some employees to reopen their accounts. They effectively created two groups, one that used Facebook, one that didn't. None of these people were choosing which group to be in, so it couldn't be that people who were unhappy were the ones choosing to use Facebook. O-Hardiness colleagues collected data about the employees from the time no one was allowed to use Facebook. And a few months after, some employees were allowed to use the social media website.
如果员工想继续在公司工作，就必须删除他们的账号。但随后，过了一段时间，公司决定允许部分员工重新开通账号。他们实际上创造了两组人，一组使用Facebook，另一组不使用。这些人都没有选择自己属于哪一组，所以绝不可能是那些不快乐的人主动选择使用Facebook。奥哈德和他的同事们收集了公司里无人被准许使用Facebook期间的数据。以及几个月后，部分员工被允许使用该社交媒体网站后的数据。
We decided to focus on Facebook effect on social comparison, the perceptions of others' lives and happiness. Social comparison, the very thing Rachel struggled with, looking at other people's lives, and trying to figure out whether she measured up. I would just scour other people's lives. I would just to compare, you know, their happiness against my happiness. Ohad and his colleagues looked at both groups and they found a few interesting things. Our first finding is that using Facebook make you more comparative.
我们决定把重点放在Facebook对社会比较、对他人生活和幸福感看法的这方面影响上。社会比较，正是蕾切尔与之挣扎的那件事——审视别人的生活，并试图弄清楚自己是否达到标准。我会去搜寻别人的生活。我只会去比较，你知道的，他们的幸福和我的幸福。奥哈德和他的同事们观察了两组人，他们发现了一些有趣的事情。我们的第一个发现是，使用Facebook会让你更具比较心理。
You compare yourself to others more often. You judge yourself, you compare am I better or worse than my friends? Am I happier? Are they happier? And so on. One surprising thing is that the study did not find that people thought others had better lives. They weren't fooled by all the happy vacation and anniversary pictures posted by their friends.
你更频繁地拿自己和他人作比较。你评判自己，你会比较：我比我的朋友更好还是更差？我更快乐吗？他们更快乐吗？诸如此类。一个令人惊讶的发现是，研究并没有发现人们认为别人过得更好。他们并没有被朋友们发布的那些快乐的度假和周年纪念照片所愚弄。
We know that people post on Facebook mostly positive things and they under post negative things about their lives. So other studies have argued that users that use Facebook think that their friends have better lives than they have. So we did not find any support for this argument and we think that maybe people make a collection in their perception and they know that people present a better version of themselves. In other words, many people reached the same conclusion that Rachel did. There's always another story. In spite of this, the researchers found that the employees who used Facebook became less happy over time compared to those who were prevented from using Facebook. Being engaged in excessive social comparison decreasedrease one's happiness. So it's not that you think that others are happier than you are
我们知道人们在Facebook上发布的大多是积极的事情，而他们关于自己生活的消极事情则发得比较少。因此，其他研究曾认为，使用Facebook的用户会认为他们的朋友过得比他们自己更好。所以我们没有为这个论点找到任何支持依据，我们认为人们或许在认知上进行了修正，他们知道人们展示的是更好的自我版本。换句话说，许多人得出了与蕾切尔相同的结论。总是有另一个故事。尽管如此，研究人员发现，与被禁止使用Facebook的人相比，使用Facebook的员工随着时间推移变得不那么快乐了。参与过度的社会比较会降低一个人的幸福感。所以，倒不是说你认为别人比你更幸福，
But you need to prove yourself to yourself over and over again and this Social comparison engagement makes you less happy. You need to prove yourself to yourself Over and over again. In other words, it's not enough for many of us to know we're having a good time. It's not enough to take a beautiful photo, filter it, post it, see how our friends react. We also want our lives to be better, or at least as good, as the lives of our friends. Comparing yourself to others doesn't just steal happiness because you discover that other people seem happier than you are.
而是你需要一次又一次地向自己证明你自己，而这种参与社会比较的行为会让你变得不那么快乐。你需要一次又一次地向自己证明你自己。换句话说，对我们许多人来说，仅仅知道自己过得开心是不够的。拍一张漂亮的照片、加个滤镜、发到网上、看着朋友们的反应，这还不够。我们还希望我们的生活比朋友们的生活更好，或者至少一样好。拿自己和他人作比较不仅会窃取快乐，因为你发现别人似乎比你更快乐；
Comparing yourself to others steals happiness because the very act of comparison takes you out of the life you're living. It takes you out of the moment. The fear that others are leading happier lives than you are has a common nickname. Phomo, the fear of missing out. This particular thing of Phomo for me came from my daughter, my daughters in her late 20s, and I just observed her friends and she experiencing Phomo and just driving themselves crazy from it.
拿自己和他人作比较之所以会窃取快乐，是因为比较这一行为本身就把你从正在经历的生活中抽离了出来。它把你从当下的时刻中抽离了出来。担心别人过得比自己更快乐，有一个通俗的昵称。FOMO，即错失恐惧症。对我而言，这种特定的FOMO情绪来自于我的女儿，我的女儿20多岁快30岁了，我只是观察她的朋友们和她自己在经历FOMO，并为此把自己折腾得精疲力竭。
Barbara Khan is a researcher at the University of Pennsylvania who studies perception and decision making. She became interested in studying formal after observing a situation with one of her daughter's friends. One of her friends chose to go to a wedding in a beautiful locale, instead of going to a beach weekend
芭芭拉·卡恩是宾夕法尼亚大学的一名研究人员，专门研究感知和决策。在观察了女儿的一位朋友所经历的情况后，她开始对研究错失恐惧症产生兴趣。这位朋友选择去一个风景优美的地方参加婚礼，而不是去海滩周末，
where the other friends were gonna be. And instead of enjoying the wedding that she was at, she was looking at Facebook and looking at the activities of her friends at this beach weekend, which was a routine thing. It wasn't a special occasion at all. Here's the crucial part. The friend who went to the exotic locale for the wedding
其他朋友都会去那里。然而，她并没有享受眼前的婚礼，而是一直在看Facebook，关注她的朋友们在这个海滩周末（这是一次常规活动，根本算不上什么特殊场合）的各种活动。以下是关键部分。去风景优美的地方参加婚礼的那位朋友
didn't think the beach was a better option. She chose to go to the wedding because she felt it was the better choice. Seeing her friends back at the beach didn't make her question her decision, but it did take her mind away from the beautiful spot she was in. I think people make decisions and then formal undermines their enjoyment of the decisions that they've made. Now, as Barbara can't points out, formal means a lot of different things to different people. It's entirely possible, for example, that the friends who went to the beach vacation
并不认为去海滩是更好的选择。她选择去参加婚礼，是因为她觉得那是更好的选择。看到朋友们回到了海滩上，并没有让她对自己的决定产生质疑，但确实把她的心思从她身处的美丽地方给带走了。我认为人们会做出决定，然后错失恐惧症会削弱他们对所做决定的享受。正如芭芭拉·卡恩所指出的，错失恐惧症对不同的人意味着许多不同的事情。例如，完全有可能的是，那些去海滩度假的朋友们
were looking at photos from the beautiful destination wedding and feeling like they were the ones who were missing out. But Barbara says the type of FOMO she ended up focusing on through a series of experiments is a very specific feeling. What we found out from a lot of experiments that we ran, the thing that was generating the fomo, the feelings of fear of missing out, it isn't really a fear, it's like a social anxiety and it's really more about what are your friends doing in building up their social group history that you're missing out on.
看着来自美丽目的地婚礼的照片，也会觉得自己才是那个错过的人。但芭芭拉说，她通过一系列实验最终关注的那种FOMO是一种非常具体的感觉。我们从开展的大量实验中发现，产生FOMO（即错失恐惧症）的东西，其实并不是一种恐惧，它更像是一种社交焦虑，而且实际上更多的是关于你的朋友们在建立他们的社交群体历史时，你在错过些什么。
So it's not really about the experience per se. In all of our experiments, we found that it was really more a function of an anxiety that something might happen in a group experience that will shape the group history in the future, that you may not be part of, and that will undermine your group belongingness. And in fact, when we went back and said, okay, if you could make this decision again, would you choose to go to the beach weekend or to the wedding, although we didn't use that example
所以这其实并不是关于体验本身。在我们所有的实验中，我们发现它实际上更多地源于一种焦虑：某种事情可能会在群体体验中发生，从而塑造未来的群体历史，而你可能没有参与其中，这会削弱你的群体归属感。事实上，当我们回过头来说，好吧，如果你能重新做出这个决定，你会选择去海滩周末还是去婚礼——虽然我们在研究中没有使用那个例子，但类似那种情况——你会选择去明显更好的体验，还是去朋友们经常进行的常规活动？几乎每一次，人们都会说：“哦，不，我会去那个异国情调的活动。”这并不是说他们不认为异国情调的活动更好、是更明智的决定。他们对做出那个决定没有任何遗憾。他们感到焦虑的是——我们用的是“焦虑”这个词——
in our studies, but that kind of thing, would you choose to go to the clearly better experience or would you go to the routine thing your friends were doing on a regular basis? Almost every time, people said, oh no, I'd go to the exotic event. It wasn't that they didn't think that the exotic event was better and the smarter decision. They had no regret about making that decision. What they were anxious about, and we're using the word anxiety,
可能是群体中会发生某些事情，从而永远改变群体的动态，而事情发生时他们却不在现场。可以肯定的是，嫉妒和社交焦虑并不是由Facebook、Instagram和Snapchat发明的。但芭芭拉·卡恩说，这些平台让我们更加意识到所有在我们缺席的情况下正在发生的事情。她进行了一系列实验，每个实验都有几百名本科生，用来测试以下假设：FOMO会削弱我们对所做决定的幸福感。我认为社交媒体所做的是，它让你能够看到朋友们正在做的那些常规事情，而你以前从未真正关注过这些事情。但当你在手机上看到它，或者，你知道的，如果你在平板电脑上
was that maybe something would happen in the group that would forever change the dynamics of the group and they wouldn't have been there when it happened. To be sure, envy and social anxiety were not invented by Facebook and Instagram and Snapchat. But Bobber Khan says, these platforms make us much more aware of all the things that are happening without us. She's run a series of experiments, each with a couple hundred undergraduates, testing the hypothesis that FOMO undermines our happiness with the decisions we've made. What I think social media does is it allows you to see these routine things your friends are doing that you really never paid much attention to before. But when you see it on your phone or, you know, if you're looking on the tablet
或在线上浏览，只是在观察朋友们在做某事而你不在场时，那是你以前看不到的情景。突然之间，你内心隐隐作痛：噢，不知道他们在聊什么，或者发生了什么。我不在场。所以，即使你花了一整天时间在哥斯达黎加热带雨林中玩滑索，当你那天晚上回到酒店查看Facebook，得知朋友们正在举行烧烤派对时，这也会削弱滑索冒险的一些乐趣。在看到朋友们在派对上的照片后，
or online and you're just observing that your friends are doing something and you're not there, that's something you didn't get to see before. And suddenly you have this pang, oh, I wonder what they're talking about or what's happening. I'm not there. So even if you spend the day zip lining through the Costa Rican rainforest, when you get back to your hotel that night and check Facebook, knowing your friends are having a barbecue and poxy, diminishes some of the pleasure of the zip lining adventure. After seeing the photos of your friends in poxy,
哥斯达黎加现在看起来就没那么神奇了。FOMO，即错失恐惧症，会导致你真正产生“错失感”。假设你有一个机会去听一场你梦寐以求、平时根本没机会看的音乐会的歌手演出，或者去一次异国度假，你选择这样做，而不是去参加朋友们的常规烧烤派对。情况就是这样设定的。所以我们说，假设你这样做了。然后实验是，在一种情况下，我们说：
Costa Rica now seems a little less magical. Fomo, the fear of missing out, leads to actually missing out. Assume you have an opportunity to go to a concert of a musician you love and you never get to see or you get to go to an exotic vacation and you choose to do that rather than go to routine barbecue with your friends. It's exactly set up like that. So we say, assume you do that. Then the experiment is, in one condition, we say,
现在假设你在度假时，拿起手机，看到朋友们在烧烤派对上玩得很开心。而在另一种情况下，也就是对照情况下，你拿起手机滚动屏幕看了一些东西，但那不是你朋友的照片。接着我们要做的是，在你查看那些照片之前，也就是在那个操纵变量之前，
now assume while you're on vacation, you pick up your phone and you see your friends enjoying themselves at the barbecue. And in the other condition, which is the control condition, you pick up your phone and you scroll and you look at something, but it's not pictures of your friends. And then what we do is we, before we ask you to look at those pictures, before that manipulation,
我们先测量你有多享受夏威夷假期或异国音乐会之类的。然后让你看或不看朋友的照片，接着我们再次测量你现在有多享受你所在的地方。我们发现，当你看了照片时，你的享受程度明显低于没有看照片的时候。芭芭拉·卡恩和她的团队正在做更多的实验，但如果他们的发现站得住脚，他们说这揭示了我们使用社交媒体的一个非常悲哀的事实。我们在那里构建的虚构世界会让我们的朋友觉得他们的生活不够好，而且
we measure how much you're enjoying your Hawaii vacation or the exotic concert or whatever. We have you either look at the pictures of your friends or not, and then we measure again how much are you enjoying where you are now. And what we find is a significant decrease in enjoyment when you've looked at the pictures then when you haven't. Bob Rakan and her team are doing more experiments, but if their findings hold, they say something really sad about our use of social media. The fictional worlds we construct there can make our friends feel their lives are inadequate and
我们的朋友构建的虚构世界会让我们的生活感觉比实际情况更加黯淡。至于蕾切尔，她现在有了一段新恋情，她说她很幸福。她有了一份新工作，她和儿子过得很好。但她觉得没有必要在Facebook上公开这一切。我不再拍很多照片了。如果我置身于当下，正在经历那个时刻，这张照片是拍给谁看的？是为了让我自己记住，还是为了……我正试图为自己、为我的儿子、也仅仅为了我自己的心理健康而活在当下。
the fictional worlds our friends construct can make our lives feel dollar than they actually are. As for Rachel, she's in a new relationship now and she says she's happy. She has a new job and she and her son are doing well. But she doesn't feel the need to publicize any of this on Facebook. I don't take a lot of pictures anymore. If I'm there in a moment and I'm having that moment, who's the picture for? Is it for me to remember or is it, I am trying to live more presently for myself and for my son and just for my own mental well-being.
她已经要求她的新男友也不要在社交媒体上发布关于他们恋情的内容。这一次，与朋友和熟人的良好关系建立起来了，我们中的一些人与同类的接触却太少了。好了，接下来我们要接听黛安娜打来的电话，向波兰斯基小队致意。嗯，希托，我是马马迪。我知道听起来有点不一样。我现在病得很重。我被诊断出患有肺炎，而且已经病了很长一段时间了。这是一个女人打进德克萨斯州KPFA电台广播节目的声音。
She has asked her new boyfriend not to post about their relationship on social media either. This time, the good with friends and acquaintances, some of us have too little contact with fellow human beings. Alright, and next up we have Diana shouting out to the Polonski unit. Um, Hito, it's Mamadi. I know it sounds kind of different. I'm very sick right now. I got diagnosed with pneumonia and sick already for quite some time now. This is the voice of a woman calling into a radio show on the Texas Station KPFA.
她有一条私人信息要带给监狱里的人。总之，我想对你说，希托，马马迪爱你。KPFA。她有一条私人信息要带给监狱里的人。总之，我想对你说，马马迪爱你。我总是想起你。而且这变得越来越难。我知道我不应该崩溃的。你会生我的气，但我忍不住对你满怀爱意。打进这样的节目是配偶、父母和孩子与囚犯（尤其是单独禁闭的囚犯）沟通的少数几种方式之一。近年来，自由派和保守派
She has a personal message for a prison in me. Anyway, I want to tell you Hito that Mamadi loves you. KPI. She has a personal message for a prison in me. Anyway, I want to tell you that Mama delves you. I always think of you. And it's getting harder and harder. I know I'm not supposed to crack it. You're gonna get mad at me, but I can't help but feel so much love for you. Calling into a program like this is one of the few ways for spouses and parents and children to communicate with prisoners, especially inmates in solitary confinement. In recent years, both liberals and conservatives
都对长期单独禁闭带来的心理和经济成本感到担忧，并对这种做法提出了质疑。在节目的后半部分，我们将探讨极少有人能见到的监狱牢房里究竟发生了什么，以及长期独处带来的心理影响。这些内容马上就到。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，您收听的是来自NPR的《隐藏的大脑》。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。社会接触是人类生活的基本方面。
worried about the psychological and financial costs of long-term solitary confinement have raised questions about the practice. In the second half of our show, we explore what happens inside the prison cells that few people ever see and the psychological effects of being alone for long periods of time. That's coming up in just a moment. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain from NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Social contact is a fundamental aspect of human life.
那么，在单独禁闭中度过大量时间，过着没有我们大多数人每天与周围人进行的数百次互动的生活，会是什么样的感觉？卡拉·梅特作家花了一十多年的时间研究孤独对这些囚犯的影响。她是加州大学尔湾分校的犯罪学教授，也是《237：鹈鹕湾监狱与长期单独禁闭的崛起》一书的作者。
So what's it like to spend vast stretches of time in solitary confinement, to live without the hundreds of interactions that most of us have with people around us every day? Caramette writer has spent more than a decade researching the effects of loneliness on these inmates. She's a professor of criminology at the University of California Irvine and the author of the book, 237. Pelican Bay Prison and the rise of long-term solitary confinement.
除了研究人员的身份外，她还曾是人权观察组织（Human Rights Watch）的囚犯权利活动人士。卡拉·梅特，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我来，尚卡尔。不了解乔治·杰克逊这个人的故事，你就无法讲述单独禁闭的故事。他在20世纪60年代初因对武装抢劫认罪而被送进监狱，被判处一年至无期徒刑。这种不定期刑期背后的想法是什么？所以对于乔治·杰克逊这样的人来说，当时的设想是他会进监狱，并且必须证明
Besides being a researcher, she has also been a prisoner's rights activist at Human Rights Watch. Karameth, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me, Shankar. You can't tell the story of solitary confinement without understanding the story of a man named George Jackson. He was sent to prison in the early 1960s after pleading guilty to armed robbery, and he was sentenced to a term of one year to life. What was the thinking behind this kind of indeterminate sentence? So the idea for someone like George Jackson was that he would go to prison and he'd have to prove
他在出狱前已经得到了改造。然而，就在杰克逊入狱前后，人们开始审视这些不定期刑期，并意识到它们正在产生真正不成比例的影响，这取决于受刑者的种族。因此，白人要说服监狱官员他们已经改过自新并应该被释放，要容易得多，
that he'd been rehabilitated before he could get out of prison. Around the time Jackson went to prison, however, people started to look at these indeterminate sentences and realize that they were having truly disproportionate impacts depending on the race of the person with the sentence. So white people had a much easier time convincing prison officials that they had been reformed and should be let out at prison
相比之下，像乔治·杰克逊这样的非裔美国男性则没那么容易。因此，乔治·杰克逊发现自己基本上被困在监狱里，多年过去了，他的假释申请一直被驳回，在这个过程中他变得激进起来。他写了一本畅销信件集，在国家和国际上都赢得了赞誉，那是写给家人和律师的信，阐述了他的革命政治观点以及诸如此类的不定期刑期所存在的问题。
than African-American men like George Jackson happen to be. So George Jackson found himself essentially stuck in prison, years went by when he was denied parole, and he became radicalized in this process. He wrote a book of best-selling letters that achieved national and international acclaim letters to his family and to his lawyers, articulating his revolutionary politics and the problems with things like this indeterminate sentence.
这引起了监狱官员的注意，在20世纪70年代初，他被指控谋杀了一名狱警，在等待针对他被指控的那起谋杀案的死刑审判期间，他被先发制人地送往圣昆廷监狱的死囚牢房。而在圣昆廷监狱一个隔离区死囚牢房里，有趣的是，有一天他的律师来看望他。监狱官员讲述并被重复了多次的故事是，他的律师把一把9毫米手枪藏在录音机里带给了他，然后杰克逊用那把枪试图从
This brought him to the attention of prison officials, and he was accused of murdering a prison guard in the early 1970s, and he was preemptively sent to death row at San Quentin while he awaited a death penalty trial for that murder he was accused of. And while on death row at San Quentin in an isolation unit interestingly, one day his lawyer came in to visit him. And the story that prison officials tell and that's been repeated many times is that his lawyer snuck a 9 millimeter gun into him inside of a tape recorder and that Jackson then used that gun to try to escape
这个隔离区逃跑。我们真正知道的全部情况是，当他跑出隔离区时，他在圣昆廷监狱的庭院里被枪杀。当工作人员冲进牢房查看发生了什么时，他们发现三名警官和另外两名囚犯被刺身亡。因此，这是加州监狱历史上
from this isolation unit. All we actually know is that he was shot to death on the San Quentin Prison Yard as he ran out of the isolation unit. And when staff ran into the unit to see what had happened, they found three officers and two more prisoners who'd been stabbed to death. So this was the most violent day in California's prison
最暴力的一天，在1971年8月21日总共发生了六起死亡事件。人们在加州总是将这一刻作为一个关键节点，认为它对于理解为什么该州需要长期单独禁闭区至关重要。美国各地也发生了类似的事情，其他州的监狱官员也提到了这些时刻。因此，在乔治·杰克逊死后两周，阿蒂卡监狱暴动发生了。
history ever, six deaths total on August 21, 1971. And this moment is a moment that people point to, in California, as incredibly important in understanding why the state needed long-term solitary confinement units. And similar things happened across the US and prison officials in other states point to those moments. So, two weeks after George Jackson died, the revolted Attica happened.
同样地，在那之后，囚犯们被锁在牢房里，这成了一个人们用来作为真正长期单独禁闭正当理由的时刻。你还讲述了一位监狱管理者卡尔·拉森的故事，他在乔治·杰克逊入狱的同一年开始了他的职业生涯。据我了解，你采访了卡尔·拉森，他的观点让我们得以一窥故事的另一面，即狱警和监狱官员如何看待单独禁闭的必要性。所以，卡尔·拉森是我在做这项工作时较早采访的人之一，令我惊讶的是，我们后来成了朋友。
Similarly, following that, prisoners were locked into their cells, and that became a moment people pointed to as a justification for really long-term solitary confinement. You also tell the story of a prison administrator, Carl Larson, who began his career the same year that George Jackson went to prison. I understand you interviewed Carl Larson, and his view gives us a glimpse into the other side of the story, how prison guards and prison officials see the need for solitary confinement. So, Carl Larson was one of the earlier people I interviewed in doing this work, and to my surprise, we got to be friends.
同样地，在此之后，囚犯们被锁在牢房里，这成为了人们用来为真正的长期单独监禁辩护的一个时刻。你还讲述了一位监狱管理者卡尔·拉尔森（Carl Larson）的故事，他的职业生涯开始于乔治·杰克逊（George Jackson）入狱的那一年。据我了解，你采访了卡尔·拉尔森，他的观点让我们得以一窥故事的另一面，即狱警和监狱官员如何看待单独监禁的必要性。所以，卡尔·拉尔森是我在做这项工作时较早采访的人之一，令我惊讶的是，我们成了朋友。
I came at this work from a perspective of a prisoner's rights advocate, very critical of the system. But as I got to know Carl Larson, I saw that he had a really interesting perspective on the system. And he was one of the first people to point me to the story of George Jackson, and to explain how scary it was to be a guard working
我最初是从囚犯权利倡导者的角度来看待这项工作的，对这个体制持高度批判的态度。但随着我对卡尔·拉尔森（Carl Larson）的了解加深，我发现他对这个体制有着非常有趣的看法。他是最早引导我关注乔治·杰克逊（George Jackson）故事的人之一，并向我解释了在20世纪70年代发生这些死亡事件时，
in the California prisons in the 1970s when these deaths were happening. And to make that fear real for me in a way that helped me to understand why he thought a long-term solitary confinement facility made sense. So Carl Larson is particularly interesting because as you said, he started out as an officer
在加州监狱里当狱警有多么可怕。他以一种让我感同身受的方式将这种恐惧具象化，从而帮助我理解为什么他认为长期单人隔离设施是合情合理的。因此，卡尔·拉尔森特别有趣，因为正如你所说，他最初是一名狱警，
in the 1970s in California prisons, actually even earlier. And then he worked his way up through the system, becoming a warden, and then becoming head of the prison construction projects that California engaged in in the 1980s, when the state built one of these long-term solitary confinement supermax facilities.
在20世纪70年代的加州监狱工作，甚至更早。后来他在体制内一步步晋升，先是成为监狱长，然后担任加州在20世纪80年代进行的监狱建设项目负责人，当时该州建造了这些长期单人隔离的超级最高安全级别监狱之一。
And he takes credit for designing one of the first of these institutions. And that's really interesting, because he's a prison administrator. He's not an architect, he's not an expert in exactly what kinds of punishments work. He didn't have a law degree, he had just worked in prisons, and he designed this completely new facility. I understand that there was some interesting architectural features of this facility, Pelican Bay. The cement for the facility was poured in one large block, and so that the cells were not built in individual units.
他因设计了其中一个最早的此类机构而居功至伟。这真的很有趣，因为他是一名监狱管理者。他不是建筑师，也不是精通哪种惩罚最有效的专家。他没有法学学位，只是在监狱里工作过，然后就设计了这个全新的设施。据我了解，这个名为“鹈鹕湾”（Pelican Bay）的设施有一些有趣的建筑特色。该设施的水泥是一大块整体浇筑的，因此单人牢房不是由单个单元建造的。
So, one of the things that's striking about the places that's made of these poured concrete cells, so they're incredibly easy to hose down, which is the fact that they can stay clean is important, because quartz earlier had criticized isolation units for being really dirty. And they're grouped together into these pods of eight. And then the pods of eight are grouped together again into these tessellated T structures, so that one officer can look out over six pods of cells at a time. So it's a modern panopticon.
因此，这些由整体浇筑混凝土牢房组成的场所的一个显著特点是，它们极易用软管冲洗，能够保持清洁这一点非常重要，因为科茨（Quartz）早些时候曾批评隔离单元非常肮脏。它们被组合成八个一组的舱（pods）。然后，这八个一组的舱又再次组合成马赛克状的T形结构，这样一名警官就可以一次俯瞰六个牢房舱。所以，这是一个现代的圆形监狱（panopticon）。
And that also, that allows the fact that there are no windows makes it really easy to just fit all these blocks together if you can imagine that structure. I'm wondering, Karamad, if you can actually just describe what one of these cells looks like. Give me a sense of what's in the cell, how big it is. What does it actually feel like to be in one of these units? So the cells in these units are generally about 8x10 feet. So imagine a wheelchair accessible bathroom stall or a generous parking space. Pretty small. You can almost reach from one end of the cell to the other. And they're fairly self-contained. So they contain a poor concrete ledge with a very thin piece of foam over it and that's the bed. And then there's another sort of concrete bit protruding that is a desk and seat combination.
这也使得——由于没有窗户，如果你能想象出那种结构，就可以非常容易地将所有这些区块组合在一起。卡拉玛特，我想知道你是否能描述一下其中一个牢房是什么样子的。让我大致了解一下牢房里有什么，它有多大。身处其中到底是什么感觉？所以，这些单元里的牢房通常大约是8乘10英尺。想象一下无障碍卫生间的隔间，或者一个宽敞的停车位。非常小。你几乎可以从牢房的一端够到另一端。而且它们相当独立。所以它们包含一个突出的混凝土壁架，上面有一块很薄的泡沫垫，那就是床。然后还有另一个突出的混凝土结构，兼作书桌和座椅。
So it's just like a concrete block that a prisoner could sit on and write there. And then there's in another corner, there's a steel usually toilet sink combination. So it's just, you know, one smooth steel object that has running water and plumbing for the prisoner. Sometimes there's just, you know, one smooth steel object that has running water and plumbing for the prisoner. Sometimes there are showers in these cells, but generally it's just a sink and a toilet. And again, if the prisoner is lucky, and they can afford
所以它就像一个混凝土块，囚犯可以坐在上面并在那里写作。然后在另一个角落，通常有一个钢制的马桶和洗手池组合。所以它只是一个光滑的钢制物件，有供囚犯使用的自来水和管道。有时这些牢房里有淋浴设施，但通常只有一个洗手池和一个马桶。再说一次，如果囚犯运气好，并且他们负担得起
it, and the system therein allows it, they might have a TV or radio. And usually they're allowed maybe a few books at a time, and a little bit of paper for writing letters or doing legal paperwork. To be clear, many prisoners in solitary have been found guilty of heinous crimes, including murder, rape, and terrorism. But here's something you might not know. Some are there because they're difficult to manage or because of bureaucratic inertia.
并且体制允许的话，他们可能会有一台电视或收音机。通常他们一次只能被允许拥有几本书，以及一点用于写信或处理法律文件的纸张。需要明确的是，许多处于单人隔离状态的囚犯都被判定犯有包括谋杀、强奸和恐怖主义在内的滔天罪行。但这里有一点你可能不知道。有些人被关在那里是因为他们难以管教，或者是由于官僚主义的因循守旧。
While judges and juries decide whether someone should go to prison, a decision that can be appealed in court, typically it's prison officials who decide whether someone should be in solitary confinement. I ask Caramette to describe the kind of prisoner who ends up in solitary. There's been shockingly little research over time on who ends up in solitary confinement and how, and it's very hard to track across states. But as people have paid more attention to this and through the work I've done, I've started to see some patterns.
虽然法官和陪审团决定某人是否应该入狱，这是一个可以在法庭上提出上诉的决定，但通常是由监狱官员来决定某人是否应该被关入单人隔离室。我请卡拉梅特描述一下最终会被关进单人隔离室的囚犯类型。令人震惊的是，长期以来关于谁最终会进入单人隔离室以及如何进入的研究少之又少，而且在各个州之间追踪这一点非常困难。但随着人们对此给予更多关注，并通过我所做的工作，我开始看到一些规律。
There's a disproportionate racial impact of solitary confinement, so we know that in our prisons in general, African Americans and Latinos are more likely to be in prison than in the general prison population, they're doubly likely, again, to be in solitary confinement than even the general prison population. That's often because gang members are being targeted for long-term isolation, especially in states like California prison systems are not putting people there based on some act or rule that they broke, but based on their status as dangerous. So, prisoners get labeled dangerous gang members and they get sent to
单人隔离会产生不成比例的种族影响，所以我们知道，在我们的监狱中，非裔美国人和拉丁裔不仅更有可能入狱，与普通监狱人口相比，他们进入单人隔离室的可能性甚至高达两倍。这通常是因为帮派成员成为长期隔离的目标，特别是在像加州这样的州，监狱系统把人关进去不是基于他们打破了什么行为或规则，而是基于他们作为危险分子的身份。因此，囚犯被贴上危险帮派成员的标签，然后被送往
isolation indefinitely. In general, I think one way to think about people who end up in isolation is that it's often the people who are really difficult for the system to manage, so that might include seriously mentally ill prisoners. There's recent research showing that transgender prisoners are really likely to end up in isolation, that pregnant women end up there. So people who the system just isn't equipped to provide resources to can end up there also.
无限期隔离。总的来说，我认为思考那些最终进入隔离室的人的一个方法是，他们往往是那些让体制极难管理的人，所以这可能包括患有严重精神疾病的囚犯。最近的研究表明，跨性别囚犯极有可能最终进入隔离室，孕妇也会被关在那里。因此，体制没有能力为其提供资源的那些人，最终也可能会被关在那里。
Caramet Rider is a professor of criminology at the University of California Irvine and the author of 23-7, Pelican Bay Prison and the rise of long-term solitary confinement. So the rise of these institutions coincided in some ways with decline or closing down of various institutions for the mentally ill, which speaks, of course, to the point that you are just making, but I also understand that this is reflected in the number of suicides we see in solitary confinement compared to the general prison population.
卡拉梅特·赖德（Caramet Rider）是加州大学欧文分校的犯罪学教授，也是《23-7：鹈鹕湾监狱与长期单人隔离的兴起》（23-7, Pelican Bay Prison and the rise of long-term solitary confinement）一书的作者。因此，这些机构的兴起在某种程度上与各种精神病收容机构的衰落或关闭同时发生，这当然印证了你刚才提出的观点，但我也了解到，这从我们在单人隔离室中看到的自杀人数与普通监狱人口的对比中也得到了反映。
Mm-hmm. There is a very close relationship between solitary confinement and mental illness. One way to understand that is that in the 1970s and early 80s when mental institutions closed was the same time that mass incarceration and rates of incarceration were increasing across the United States. And that meant that some mentally ill people unsurprisingly ended up in prisons. And one of the arguments I make is that as those people
嗯嗯。单人隔离与精神疾病之间存在着非常紧密的联系。理解这一点的一种方式是，在20世纪70年代和80年代初精神病院关闭的同时，美国各地的大规模监禁和监禁率也在不断上升。这意味着一些患有精神疾病的人毫不意外地最终进入了监狱。我提出的观点之一是，随着这些人
ended up in prison, they tended to be put into solitary confinement. And that's one explanation for the fact that rates of suicide and solitary confinement can be twice as high as in the general prison population or even higher. And that rates of mental illness and isolation can be high. And often there's a real chicken and egg problem of, you know, did a person get sent to
进入监狱，他们往往会被关进单人隔离室。这是对以下事实的一种解释：单人隔离室中的自杀率可能是普通监狱人口的两倍甚至更高。而且隔离室中的精神疾病发病率也很高。通常这里存在一个真正的“先有鸡还是先有蛋”的问题，即一个人是因为患有精神疾病而被送进隔离室的——各州曾试图限制这一点，还是说身处隔离室的人患上了精神疾病？
isolation because they were mentally ill and states have tried to limit that, or do people in isolation develop mental illnesses? Most of us are never going to see the inside of a supermax, but we often do see scenes of solitary confinement described in pop culture. One of those examples is the TV show Orange is the new black. We have a bit of tape. The character Piper is put into a security housing unit and starts speaking to a voice, she hears through the grate of her cell.
我们大多数人永远都不会见到超级最高安全级别监狱的内部，但我们经常在流行文化中看到对单人隔离场景的描述。其中一个例子就是电视剧《女子监狱》（Orange is the New Black）。我们有一段录音。角色派珀（Piper）被关进安全住房单元，开始和一个声音说话，那是她通过牢房的格栅听到的声音。
How long have you been down here? I lost track. I know. Nine months. A year? How long have you been down here? I lost track. I know. Nine months? A year? A year? That's insane.
你在这里呆了多久了？我记不清了。我知道。九个月？一年？你在这里呆了多久了？我记不清了。我知道。九个月？一年？一年？这太疯狂了。
I keep the lights on. See, it was all sensitive. It's not living. I mean, yeah, you're breathing. You're taking up the personal moral. It's bad. Start to see the f***ing thing there. Start to hear voices.
我一直开着灯。你看，一切都很敏感。这根本不算生活。我是说，对，你在呼吸。你在占用个人道德空间。这太糟了。开始看到他妈的那些东西在那儿。开始听到声音。
Oh my God. Keep you here until they break. I feel like I'm gonna throw up. Karamit, I'm wondering how accurate that description is of what lives actually like in solitary confinement? I do think that the disembodied voice that you hear talking to a paper is accurate on a number of levels. The voice is kind of flattened and affect, and the prisoner was describing hearing voices, hallucinations. That's a very common side effect of isolation. And people talk about time, the way they perceive time-changing
天哪。留着你直到你崩溃。我觉得我想吐。卡拉梅特，我想知道这种对单人隔离中真实生活的描述有多准确？我确实认为，你听到对派珀说话的那个虚无飘渺的声音在多个层面上是准确的。那个声音有点扁平且缺乏情感，而囚犯描述的是听到声音、幻觉。这是隔离的一个非常普遍的副作用。人们谈论时间，他们感知时间流逝的方式发生了变化，
because there is no way to mark time. People talk about it exactly as that prisoner said, it's not that it even feels long. It's just that it's almost endless. That days can kind of in a weird counterintuitive way fly by because there's nothing marking anything about a day or a week. So in that sense, it's accurate. I would have spent a moment talking about your own role in looking at this.
因为没有办法标记时间。人们的说法完全就像那个囚犯所说的那样，并不是说它甚至感觉很长。只是它几乎是无止境的。由于没有任何东西来标记一天或一周的任何事情，日子可以以一种奇怪的、违反直觉的方式飞逝。从这个意义上说，它是准确的。我想花点时间谈谈你自己在审视这个问题时所扮演的角色。
On the one hand, you're a researcher who has spend time studying the question, but as you yourself have said, you're also a prison rights advocate. You've been an activist at Human Rights Watch and other organizations. How do you preserve your ability to be analytical about the subject, while you also have what are very clearly strong views about solitary confinement. You know, when I went to interview Carl Larson, he said, well, you're a Berkeley liberal. So he asked me to do some background reading
一方面，你是一位花时间研究这个问题的研究人员，但正如你自己所说，你也是一名监狱权利倡导者。你曾是人权观察组织和其他组织的积极分子。当你对单人隔离有着非常明确的强烈观点时，你如何保持对这个主题进行客观分析的能力？你知道，当我采访卡尔·拉尔森时，他说，好吧，你是个伯克利自由派。所以他要求我做一些背景阅读，
and prove that I was serious and I would listen to him. And so I actually think in the process of doing this work, I have become more open-minded and been criticized by advocates for talking so directly and so extensively to prison officials. And so I've had the interesting experience of trying to keep the conversation open across a really broad spectrum of perspectives on this process. And I think in that way, I've been able to try to at least incorporate these different perspectives and tease apart the arguments and the positions people are coming from. And I do think that in reform, prison officials have to walk into these institutions and engage with
证明我是认真的，并且我会听他讲。因此我实际上认为，在做这项工作的过程中，我变得更加思想开放了，并且因为与监狱官员进行如此直接和广泛的对话而受到倡导者的批评。因此，我经历了一段有趣的经历，试图在这个过程的极其广泛的观点谱系中保持对话的开放。我认为通过这种方式，我至少能够试图将这些不同的 perspectivas（观点）结合起来，并剖析这些论点和人们的立场。而且我确实认为，在改革中，监狱官员必须走进这些机构，日复一日地与
these prisoners day in and day out, and they also need to be part of the reform conversation. And through this process, you know, surprisingly, even though I came basically from the other side, if you want to think of it in terms of sides, I've come to see that perspective. Karamit, what sorts of things do people in solitary confinement say they miss? What are the kind of things that you miss that the rest of us might not think about? So people talk about not having seen the moon in years or decades and how much they miss that. And then people talk about missing just pure human
这些囚犯打交道，他们也需要成为改革对话的一部分。通过这个过程，你知道，令人惊讶的是，尽管我基本上是从对立面来的——如果你想从阵营的角度来考虑的话，我已经开始理解那种视角了。卡拉梅特，身处单人隔离中的人说他们最想念的是什么样的事情？有哪些是你怀念而我们其他人可能不会想到的事情？所以人们谈论的是已经好几年或几十年没有见过月亮了，以及他们多么怀念这一点。然后人们谈论的是仅仅怀念纯粹的人类
touch. And you know, I tell a story in the book about a prisoner who, his cell door and the cell door of the prisoner next to him were accidentally opened at the same time and they were rival gang members. But they had been talking to each other, shouting through the, through the cell walls. And when the cell doors opened, they just reached around and grabbed each other's hands and held on, because it had been so long since either of them had had a gentle human touch like that. Prisoners often stay alone in their cells for 22 or 23 hours a day, and you found that perhaps the only way to actually manage this psychologically is to stick to
触觉。你知道，我在书里讲了一个故事，一个囚犯，他的牢房门和旁边囚犯的牢房门同时被意外打开了，他们是敌对帮派的成员。但他们一直在隔着牢房墙壁互相交谈、大喊大叫。当牢房门打开时，他们只是伸手过去抓住了对方的手并紧紧握住，因为他们两个人都已经有太长时间没有感受到那种温柔的人类触感了。囚犯们通常每天独自呆在牢房里22或23个小时，你发现心理上应对这一情况的唯一方法可能就是坚持
a series of very, very rigid routines. Tell me about those routines. The prisoners who I was able to interview in this research to understand their experiences tended to be the prisoners who survived. And so they did develop all kinds of coping mechanisms. And one of the ones I heard about again and again was that they would wake up, you know, first thing in the morning, 5 a.m., and they would do thousands of repetitive exercises, often what prisoners call burpees, so a combination of jumping jacks, push-ups, and sit-ups.
一系列非常非常严格的常规。跟我讲讲这些常规。在这项研究中我有幸采访到以了解他们经历的囚犯，往往都是那些幸存下来的人。因此，他们确实开发了各种应对机制。我一次又一次听到的一种机制是，他们会在一大清早，比如早上5点醒来，然后做数千次重复性的运动，通常是囚犯们所说的“波比跳”（burpees），也就是开合跳、俯卧撑和仰卧瘫（应为仰卧起坐）的结合。
And, you know, literally a few thousand in the morning to start out their day. And then clean their cells, write letters, work on legal cases. And in general in these units, if prisoners are following the rules and they have money being sent in from family, they can buy either a TV or a radio. And prisoners who develop these routines talk about really limiting the time
你知道，早上字面意义上要做几千个来开始他们的一天。然后打扫牢房，写信，处理法律案件。通常在这些单元里，如果囚犯遵守规则并且有家人汇款进来，他们可以买一台电视或收音机。那些建立起这些常规的囚犯谈到，他们真正限制了自己
they spent listening to media. So maybe only an hour a day or two hours a day or a special show they like to watch so that they were keeping both their bodies and their minds really busy consciously over the course of a day. And interestingly, prisoners talk about having trouble letting go of these routines once they got out of prison, that they would still do those thousands of burpees every morning at 5am when they got up, and that their ability to control everything in their space in that 8x10 cell they live in is also hard to let go of. That they could keep, you know,
听媒体的时间——比如可能每天只有一两个小时，或者看一个他们喜欢的特别节目——这样他们就有意识地在一天当中让自己的身体和大脑都非常忙碌。有趣的是，囚犯们谈到，当他们出狱后，很难戒掉这些常规，当他们每天早上5点起床时，他们仍然会做那几千个波比跳，而且他们在他们生活的那个8x10英尺的牢房里控制自己空间内一切的能力也很难放下。他们可以保持，你知道的，
President described to me how he could keep the cap of his toothpaste perfectly clean, and it was really hard when he had a roommate when he got out of prison. The fact that he couldn't control the cap of the toothpaste anymore. So, it kind of gives you a sense of how intense it is to survive and then how long those coping mechanisms linger afterwards. You talk in the book, Caramette, about inmates trying a number of different things to not just be physically active and mentally active, but emotionally expressive to try and find ways to do artistic things. Can you talk about that for a moment? Prisoners do struggle to find ways to express themselves. Sometimes that's becoming really good at the law and litigating cases, but very often it's teaching themselves to draw,
一个囚犯向我描述他是如何把牙膏盖保持得一尘不染的，当他出狱后有了室友时，这真的很难改变。他再也无法控制牙膏盖了。所以，这在某种程度上让你体会到生存是多么激烈，以及那些应对机制在事后会持续多久。卡拉梅特，你在书中谈到，囚犯们尝试了许多不同的事情，不仅是为了保持身体和心理的活跃，还要表达情感，试图寻找进行艺术创作的方法。你能谈谈那个吗？囚犯们确实在努力寻找表达自我的方式。有时那是变得非常擅长法律和诉讼案件，但通常是自学画画，
sometimes teaching themselves to speak a new language, sometimes teaching themselves to sew. One of my favorite stories was a prisoner who told me that he was in isolation for a number of months, and I'm not even sure how he made himself a needle. I know that he pulled threads out of the jumpsuits they're given in order to make thread, and then he started tailoring his clothes so that they fit better. They're often given these very loose jumpsuits, and so he would add cuffs or shorten the sleeves. And I think other prisoners found out about him doing this.
有时自学说一门新语言，有时自学缝纫。我最喜欢的故事之一是一个囚犯告诉我，他在隔离室里呆了好几个月，我甚至不确定他是怎么给自己做一个针的。我知道他是从发给他们的连体工服抽线来做线，然后他开始裁剪他的衣服以便更合身。发给他们的通常是这些非常宽松的连体衣，所以他会加上袖口或者缩短袖子。我想其他囚犯发现他做这事。
And in some cases, a friendly officer would pass a uniform back and forth. And he started tailoring other people's uniforms. It's kind of not that anyone is even seeing them. But it's this amazing kind of self-expression and community that they're managing to create in this place. I'm sure they're going to be people who say, look, there are lots of people in these units
在某些情况下，一个友好的警官会把制服传来传去。他开始为其他人改制服。这甚至谈不上有人能看到它们。但这是他们在这种地方设法创造的一种了不起的自我表达和社群。我确信会有这样的人说，听着，这些单元里有很多人
who really are the worst of the worst. Maybe not all of them are, but some of them probably are. Some of them probably are really violent and really dangerous, and ought to be there. And I'm wondering, do you ever feel that they might be people who need to be in solitary confinement? So there are certainly people in isolation who are dangerous.
确实是十恶不赦之徒。也许并非所有人都是，但其中一些人可能确实是。其中一些人可能真的很暴力、真的很危险，理应待在那里。我想知道，你是否曾觉得他们可能确实是需要被关进单人隔离室的人呢？所以，隔离室里确实关着一些危险分子。
One of the really important points of analysis is the length of time people are spending in isolation, the fact that people, we're not talking about weeks or months, we're talking about years and decades often, and that even people who might have been fairly scary or dangerous in their 20s are unlikely to be that way into their 40s and 50s. And as we look at decades of these policies, we see that even some of the people who have been held up as the scariest, the system didn't control them very well while they were in it, and they're doing surprisingly well outside of isolation. So it really does call the practice into question on all different levels.
分析中非常重要的一点是人们在隔离室中度过的时间长度，事实上人们——我们讨论的不是几周或几个月，我们讨论的往往是几年和几十年，而且即使是那些在20多岁时可能相当可怕或危险的人，到了40多岁和50多岁时也不太可能是那样了。当我们回顾这些政策的几十年时，我们看到，即使是那些被认为最可怕的人，当他们在里面时，体制也没有很好地控制他们，而他们在隔离室外面时表现得出奇地好。因此，这确实在各个不同的层面上对这种做法提出了质疑。
So your book comes at a time when many liberals and conservatives have joined hands to call for prison reform, for one thing, keeping people in prison and keeping someone in solitary confinement is very, very expensive. Give us a sense of how expensive it is and whether these ideological pairings are triggering any change in the system.
所以你的书出版之际，正值许多自由派和保守派携手呼吁监狱改革，一方面，把人关在监狱里以及把人关在单人隔离室里是非常非常昂贵的。请让我们大致了解一下这有多昂贵，以及这些意识形态的结合是否正在引发体制内的任何变化。
So, solitary confinement is astronomically expensive. In states like California, it costs about $45,000 per prisoner per year to keep someone in the general prison population, and it costs about $90,000 per prisoner per year to keep someone in isolation. So the cost of running the facilities is really expensive because these prisoners in isolation, every need has to be met by someone working in the prison, whether it's delivering mail or delivering legal documents or getting them a meal.
所以，单人隔离的成本高得惊人。在像加州这样的州，将某人关在普通监狱人口中每年花费约45,000美元，而将某人关在隔离室中每年花费约90,000美元。因此，运营这些设施的成本确实很高，因为这些处于隔离状态的囚犯，每一个需求都必须由在监狱里工作的人来满足，无论是分发信件、分发法律文件还是给他们送饭。
And so that's how the costs go up. And the cost of the facilities are also expensive to build these kinds of technologically advanced facilities and that's not even wrapped into that per-presenter per year cost. So I think that has been part of the reform conversation as you suggest that perhaps there might be a less expensive way to do this work. One other cost of isolation is that the vast majority of people even from long-term solitary confinement, ultimately get out of prison. It's 95 to 98 percent of all prisoners get out eventually, and that's surprisingly true
这就是成本上升的方式。而且建造这些技术先进的设施本身的建设成本也很昂贵，这甚至还没有被计入那个“每名囚犯每年”的成本中。所以我认为，正如你所暗示的那样，这已经是改革对话的一部分，也许有一种成本更低的办法来做这项工作。隔离的另一个成本是，绝大多数人——即使是那些来自长期单人隔离的人——最终都会出狱。95%到98%的囚犯最终都会出狱，令人惊讶的是，这也是事实
of people in isolation too, and so there's the question of what are the social impacts of letting people out. And I think in combination, those economic costs and the social costs, people are beginning to think about alternatives, and that is a conversation that is cross- this political lines and prison as I suggested in many states legislators are initiating reforms some litigation has happened but in many states prison officials within the system are looking at the norms changing in the critiques of this practice and initiating their own reforms saying what can we do to reduce our reliance on this practice
对于隔离室里的人来说也是如此，因此这就产生了放人出狱会对社会产生什么影响的问题。我认为结合经济成本和社会成本，人们开始考虑替代方案，这是一场跨越政治阵线的对话，正如我在许多州的监狱中暗示的那样，立法者正在发起改革，一些诉讼已经发生，但在许多州，体制内的监狱官员正在审视规范的变化以及对这种做法的批评，并主动发起自己的改革，说我们能做些什么来减少对这种做法的依赖
and initiating their own reforms, saying what can we do to reduce our reliance on this practice? Karamad Rider is a professor at the University of California at Irvine. She is the author of the book, 23-7, Pelican Bay Prison, and the rise of long-term solitary confinement. Karamad, thank you for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thanks for having me. This week's show was produced by Maggie Pennman and Parts Shah. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Reena Cohen, Jenny Schmidt and Renee Clarre. Our engineers are Andy Huthur and Jay Ciz. NPR's Vice President for Programming and Audience Development is Anya Grunman.
并主动发起自己的改革，说我们能做些什么来减少对这种做法的依赖？卡拉梅特·赖德是加州大学欧文分校的教授。她是《23-7：鹈鹕湾监狱与长期单人隔离的兴起》一书的作者。卡拉梅特，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。谢谢邀请我。本周的节目由玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Pennman）和帕茨·沙（Parts Shah）制作。由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括丽娜·科恩（Reena Cohen）、珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）和蕾妮·克拉尔（Renee Clarre）。我们的工程师是安迪·胡瑟（Andy Huthur）和杰伊·西兹（Jay Ciz）。NPR负责节目和听众拓展的副总裁是安雅·格伦曼（Anya Grunman）。
If you like the show, check out our weekly podcast. Search for Hidden Brain in NPR1 iTunes or wherever you find your podcasts. You can also follow the show on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen to my stories on morning edition each week on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢这个节目，请查看我们的每周播客。在NPR1、iTunes或你寻找播客的任何地方搜索“Hidden Brain”。你也可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注本节目，并在每周的当地公共广播电台的《早间版》（Morning Edition）节目中收听我的故事。我是尚卡尔·韦达姆（Shankar Vedantum）。下周见。这个单集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。